die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit Jana
pareigis herzlich willkommen Fußball und
Rugby gibt's gleich von Norbert König ja
guten Abend werfen wir einen Blick auf
die großen Nachrichten Themen
heute Israel verstärkt Luftangriffe das
Militär bombardiert auch ein Ziel im
Westjordanland und ein weiterer
Hilfskonvoi bleibt an der Grenze zu Gaza
hängen solidaritätsdemo für Israel in
Berlin gehen tausende Menschen gegen
Antisemitismus auf die
Straße und Auszeichnung für einen
unbeugsam Salman rusti bekommt den
Friedenspreis des Deutschen
Buchhandels die Sorgen wachsen dass sich
der Krieg im Nahen Osten ausweitet der
US-amerikanische Verteidigungsminister
austtin kündigte an zusätzliche Truppen
in Bereitschaft zu versetzen israels
Ministerpräsident Netanyahu warnte die
libanesische hisbolla Miliz davor in den
Krieg einzutreten über die Lage in den
palästinensischen Gebieten und in Israel
berichtet Alissa
jung der israelische Armeechef vor
seiner Truppe erschwört Sie ein auf eine
äußerst schwierige Mission Gaza ist
komplex dicht besiedelt wir werden eine
operative professionelle Mission starten
um die Hamas fununktionäre zu
vernichten die israelische Luftwaffe
hatte in der Nacht mehrere Ziele in Gaza
und auch diese Moschee im Westjordanland
bombardiert dort soll sich nach Angaben
der Armee eine Terrorzelle befunden
haben in Gaza hätte man Dutzende
hamaskämpfer getötet nach
palästinensischen Angaben geraten dabei
täglich Zivilisten unter Beschuss der
Armeesprecher fordert erneut verlassen
sie den Norden man werde die Angriffe
dort verstärken es sind zwei Wochen auf
der Flucht voller Angst für die Menschen
in Israel und den palästinensischen
Gebieten wo bleibt die internationale
Hilfe fragen Sie in Gaza wo sind die
arabischen Regierungen wir wollen dass
die Regierungen an unserer Seite stehen
sehen sie nicht was mit uns geschieht
sie müssen ihre Augen öffnen wir
brauchen Waffenstillstand heute und die
nächsten Tage erst sah es so aus als Cam
heute neue Hilfslieferungen rein nach
Gaza doch bislang haben sie es nicht
über die Grenze geschafft und in Israel
fragen sie verzweifelt wo sind unsere
Geiseln sie sollten nur eine Mission
haben meine Familie zurückzubringen
210 Menschen sind noch immer in den
Händen der
Hammers in Berlin haben heute laut
Polizei rund 10 000 Menschen für
Solidarität mit Israel und gegen
Antisemitismus demonstriert mit dabei
auch der Bundespräsident wir sagen
unseren Freunden in Israel und allen
Jüdinnen und Juden ihr seid nicht allein
wir stehen in diesen furchtbaren Stunden
an eurer Seite sagte frankwalter
Steinmeier zu dem Protest aufgerufen
hatte ein breites Bündnis aus Politik
Kirchen und Verbänden mehr von Henriette
demesier es sind viele gekommen viele
die hier in Berlin gut zwei Wochen nach
dem brutalen Überfall der Hamas auf
Israel ein Zeichen setzen wollen gegen
Antisemitismus und für Solidarität weil
meine ganze Familie ja betroffen
persönlich betroffen ist weil es für uns
einfach ja ein Teil unserer Identität
ist vor allen Dingen auch ein Zeichen
zusetzen an die jüdischen Mitbürger die
hier wohnen um zu anderes Bild von der
Öffentlichkeit zu zeichnen als das was
Berlin in den letzten Tagen gezeichnet
hat stehen an der Seite Israels und zwar
auch ganz Israels und wollen einfach
sagen wir unterstützen euch auf der
Kundgebung betont Bundespräsident
Steinmeier unser Land sei gefordert wie
lange nicht es ist unerträglich dass jüd
und Juden heute wieder Angst haben
ausgerechnet in unserem Land jeder
Einzel Angriff auf Jüdin und Juden auf
jüdische Einrichtung ist eine Schande
für Deutschland Politik und
Zivilgesellschaft aber auch Angehörige
von israelischen Geiseln stehen zusammen
wie Roni Romann sie hofft auf die
Freilassung ihrer Schwester die heute
Geburtstag
hat 85 Jahre nachdem meine Großmutter
aus Deutschland floh komme ich nun
zurück und bitte euch um Hilfe lasst
mich nicht allein denn noch haben wir
die Chance auf ein kleines happy
am Abend werden in Berlin dann 1400
Lichter angezündet in Gedenken an die
seit dem Angriff ermordeten in
Israel ein klares Signal für das
Judentum in Deutschland ging heute auch
von Dessau aus dort wurde eine neue
Synagoge eingeweiht es ist der erste
Neubau eines jüdischen Gotteshauses in
SachsenAnhalt seit der Schoa an der
Zeremonie nahm unter anderem
Bundeskanzler Scholz Ministerpräsident
haselow und der israelische Botschafter
Teil die neue Synagoge steht fast an
derselben Stelle wo die alte Synagoge
während des Novemberpogroms
1938 durch die Nationalsozialisten
zerstört
wurde Gesundheitsminister Lauterbach
plant dass Eltern leichter Kinder
Krankengeld beantragen können wir setzen
durch dass Eltern nicht mehr am ersten
Tag an dem das Kind krank ist zum Arzt
laufen müssen sagte er der Bild am
Sonntag das sei unsinnige Bürokratie
künftig solle der Arztbesuch erst ab dem
vierten Tag notwendig
werden Deutschland sichert der Ukraine
weitere Unterstützung zu 200 Millionen
Euro sollen für Bildung
Gesundheitsversorgung Trinkwasser und
den Wiederaufbau bereitgestellt werden
so entwicklungsstaatssekretär flasbart
in hakev sind bei einem Raketenangriff
am Samstagabend sechs Menschen getötet
und mindestens 16 verletzt worden
meldeten ukrainische Behörden
eine russische Rakete hatte ein
Postlager
getroffen auf den Kanarischen Inseln
kommen immer mehr Flüchtlinge an allein
gestern waren es mehr als 1000 an einem
einzigen Tag die sieben spanischen
Inseln im Atlantik sind zum Hauptziel
von flüchttingen aus dem Senegal und
weiteren Ländern südlich der Sahara
geworden in diesem Jahr erreichten bis
Mitte Oktober mehr als 23 000 Menschen
die Kanaren 80% mehr als im
Vorjahreszeitraum
es ist einer der seltenen öffentlichen
Auftritte des schriftstellerers Salman
rusti nach dem Attentat auf ihn im
vergangenen Jahr weltweit war damals der
Schock groß in Frankfurt ist seiman
rusti heute mit dem Friedenspreis des
Deutschen Buchhandels ausgezeichnet
worden ein Preis mit besonderer
Bedeutung gerade in diesen Tagen für
einen Mann der seit Jahrzehnten unter
Polizeischutz leben muss Peter teisen
berichtet als großes Vorbild wird sal R
heute würdigt in einer Zeit der
Einschüchterung egal ob durch Islamisten
oder den Mob im Netz sei er eine der
bedeutendsten Stimmen für Freiheit und
gegen
Fanatismus der vielleicht wichtigste
Verteidiger der Freiheit von Kunst und
Rede in unserer Zeit vor allem aber ein
Weiser neugieriger heiterer und gütiger
Mensch und somit der würdigste Träger
den es für diese Auszeichnung die ja als
Friedenspreis ausdrücklich nicht nur
künstlerische sondern auch humanistische
Größe würdigt überhaupt hätte geben
können wortgewaltig aber immer friedlich
fast wäre diese Stimme für immer
verstummt als vor 14 Monaten ein
radikaler Islamist bei einer Lesung auf
ihn einsticht rusti überlebt ganz knapp
bereits 1989 hatte Ayatollah romeni mit
einer Fatwa zu Mord an rusti aufgerufen
wegen der Satanischen Verse große
Literatur für fanatische Muslime aber
eine Provokation die Freiheit des Wortes
sieht Rus die in Zeiten von Fake News
wieder in
Gefahr wir sollten weiterhin und mit
frischem Elan machen was wir immer schon
tun mussten schlechte rede mit besserer
Rede Kontern falschen narrativen bessere
entgegensetzen auf Hass mit Liebe
Antworten und nicht die Hoffnung
aufgeben dass ich die Wahrheit selbst in
einer Zeit der Lügen durchsetzen
kann ein großer Autor eine unbeugsame
Stimme nach den Jahrzehnten des Hasses
und der Mord gegen ih ist es ein kleines
Wunder dass Salman rusti den
Friedenspreis heute entgegennehmen
konnte in der Schweiz wurde heute ein
neues Parlament gewählt 200 Sitze im
Nationalrat und 46 Sitze im Ständerat
der die Kantone vertritt laut aktuellen
Hochrechnungen zeichnet sich ein
Rechtsruck ab die migrationskritische
SVP gewinnt dazu und ist weiter klar
stärkste
Kraft in der Fußballbundesliga der
Frauen nun auch der VfL Wolfsburg die
ersten Punkte abgegeben ja und zwar im
ersten schlussfurt sogar gerade noch die
Niederlage vermieden im Spitzenspiel
bestätigen die Gäste aus Hoffenheim
nämlich ihre gute Form und müssen sich
erst kurz vor Schluss mit einem 2 Z2
Unentschieden zufrieden geben es bleibt
beim zweipunkte Rückstand auf
Tabellenführer
Wolfsburg die Willenskraft einer
Alexandra Pop wirkt noch immer mit 2:0
waren die Tabellen zweiten aus
Hoffenheim durch Mar Alber bereits in
gegangen doch dann rüttelt Pop ihre nach
dem Champions League aus noch immer
letargischen Mitspielerinnen wach nach
faul an ihr verwandelt Jansen den
Strafstoß zum
1:2 und kurz vor Schluss macht es die
VfL Kapitänin selbst und wie
2:2 Tabellenführung doch noch
verteidigt und er ist Saisonsieg für die
Männer des ersten fC Köln nach dem 3:1
im reheinischen Derby gegen Borussia
Mönchen Gladbach ist jetzt wieder me05
Tabellen letzter das Traumfinale bei der
Rugby Weltmeisterschaft ist perfekt
Titelverteidiger Südafrika gewinnt im
stad de France in Paris das zweite
Halbfinale ganz knapp gegen England und
trifft am Samstag auf Neuseeland die All
Blacks waren ebenfalls schon dreimal
Weltmeister Team England in Weiß führt
11 Minuten Verschluss mit 15 Z6 dann
dreht Südafrika auf ann dringt mit dem
Ball zum ersten Mal für die Weltmeister
ins mahlfeld der Engländer ein der
Beginn der aufohjagd die 3 Minuten vor
dem Ende in den Sieg mündet andre
Pollard schon im wm-fale vor 4er Jahren
überragend bringt einen Straftritt aus
49 m ins Ziel die entscheidenden drei
Punkte zum 16 Z 155 Sieg nach dem Finale
am Samstag zwischen Neuseeland und
Südafrika wird ein Land das erste sein
das zum vierten Mal den Rugby
Weltmeister stellt und Tor ohne Latte
danke schön
gucken wir wie das Wetter wird nach
Nebelauflösung ist es im Nord und
Südosten länger sonnig von Südwesten
breiten sich dichte Wolken aus am
Nachmittag mit Regen bei 12 bis
18° um
21:45 Uhr begrüßt die Anne gellineck zum
heutejournal und jetzt übergebe ich an
Theo Koll der heute das letzte Mal
Berlin direkt moderieren wird